hello and welcome to Entertainment
Tonight I'm Kevin Frazier the big buzz
coming out of New York City so let's get
right to it
[Applause]
okay the moment we've all been waiting
for Mom and Dad made it to the Met Bree
is working that dress tonight free who
are you wearing tonight
[Applause]
[Music]
let's stick over here that's from my
lady
the couple was the last to arrive on the
cream carpet showing up after 10 pm the
soon to be Mama of two got some help
from ASAP revealing her baby bump in
front of our cameras
[Music]
or maybe you have
you have got here right
how was the second pregnancy I think
different from the first one
um just everything all of my
no Cravings tons of nausea everything's
different but I'm enjoying it I'm
enjoying it I feel good I feel energetic
[Music]
free race look by the Numbers each of
those flowers took 30 hours to make and
that train it was 16 feet long and took
five people to handle it how's the
little man doing
growing big beautiful happy baby thank
you for asking congratulations on baby
earlier in the day ASAP was caught in a
giant crowd trying to get back into the
couple's hotels then this happened
[Music]
he's like sweetheart I need to get
through and I went no and how'd you like
to be this girl Madeline lannis lost her
glasses when ASAP pushed her out of the
way she told us exclusively he kind of
thanked me and laughed and then went
inside I wasn't injured in any way and
my glasses are perfectly fine ASAP
tweeted his apologies earlier today LOL
my fault sweetheart
Riri ended the nights at 6am she left a
diner and another all-white look this
time totally bearing her baby bump
you've got obviously your beautiful
growing family you've got the new Smurf
movie but honey when we're gonna work
our nine into the mix sis
you know what when I do when I'm ready
yeah I'm coming straight to you first
and while Rihanna for sure rocked the
Carl Lagerfeld theme Jared Leto really
went for it dressing up as Carl's
beloved cat shupat
oh it's you the celebs were loving it
and Hathaway Salma Hayek Jimmy Fallon
and Ashley Park so I just ran into a
giant cat I knew Carl he was always such
a kind man to me I could just imagine
him looking down with a big smile on his
face uh seeing shoe pet and All His
glory is his favorite little cat you
know I'm playing Carl in a movie the
first time I met him I said to him I
said you know one day I I've got to be
you on film and he said to me uh only
you my love only you
looked a little perplexed giving Jared a
hug and wingy wanted to make sure she
they don't got no chairs no cocktails
[Music]
[Applause]
inside Liza wore a mirrored Fendi coats
and dazzled Med audience with a surprise
performance singing her hits
and playing Mozart on her flute
[Music]
but back to the feline fun
that's an all silver little nasdex in a
metallic thong with crystals from
Austria how long were you in makeup
today
makeup that took nine hours
are you gonna be uncomfortable inside be
honest I probably will are you gonna
take dinner I don't know how you're
gonna get food in your mouth I probably
won't so how many cats has there already
been you're cat number two
turns out there were three we should
have had your inspiration tonight
Remy winner Doja cats wore Prosthetics
on her face and a silver hooded gown
complete with cat ears over 5 000 hours
of work went into creating these
stunning outfits and check out those
claws I mean Nails Doja how long did the
transformation take how many hours
[Applause]
as for the real shoe pets well believe
it or not the Beloved 11 year old cat
has her own InStep she posted that while
she loves the support she turned down
the red carpet invites to stay cozy at
home and which stores avoided
potentially awkward run-ins Q Harry
Styles exes
[Applause]
happy belated birthday to you young lady
thank you this is my birthday party
welcome Olivia Wilde and Harry's recent
makeout partner Emily radakowski arrived
just 15 minutes apart this newly blonde
39 year old is moving on what have you
been reflecting on when it comes to this
year oh my God I mean I just feel so
lucky I feel like this is just a
wonderful time and I'm working hard and
you know my kids are healthy and things
are good you are single and ready to
mingle now so a solo imrata and Tory
Burch gave us Audrey Hepburn Vibes and
was quoting queen bee how are you
finding the dating life now these days
because it's been a minute since you've
been here
um it's good we'll see maybe tonight you
know meet my husband
well remember when Emily dated this guy
hey Pete a Buckethead we're in P
Davidson hit the carpet Solo in less
than three minutes before his ex 2022
Met Gala date MK
oh but the two got together later
chatting inside with us sure more on
that in a sec Kim's dates her younger
sisters mom to two Kylie with a cape
cover-up left their hotel hand in hand
with five-year-old stormy Kim brought
nine-year-old Northwest but since the
Mets 18 plus it was Mama's only on the
carpet
took us back to this look but with over
50 000 freshwater pearls some wound up
popping up in the car I told my daughter
to grab them all they're real pearls and
she was putting them all in her purse
Kylie Jenner bombshell in red Kylie and
Kim posed with pantless sis Kendall
towering over both of them with these
eight inch platforms
three minutes later her rumored man Bad
Bunny arrived backless in all white he
kinda went up Kendall with a more than
26 foot long floral train look at that
smile you are bringing it mister the 29
year old singer hopped into the car
dinner Sprinter van quit changing to hit
up the After parties with Kendall a
source tells E.T they're getting closer
and closer every day he genuinely makes
her happy and there is no drama but back
to Kim and Usher what's up with these
two she's sort of in a fixture at his
Vegas show
[Music]
I've been not once but what twice I mean
it's a good show you know what I'm
saying why not let's see a little
meanwhile jayliff slayed in Manhattan so
low Ben Affleck avoided being yet
another Meme and sat this one out if
it's not gonna be fun then why do it be
home with my husband and my kids Mrs
Affleck War Ralph Lauren the same
designer as her wedding dress the custom
halter gown required two handlers to get
that train picture perfect
solo star Gisele Bundchen who twirled
into single life like an icon
awesome The Gatlin Mark the supermodel's
first red carpet since her divorce from
Tom Brady and how's this for what could
have been an interesting after-party
run-in Giselle was spotted entering the
same events as X Leonardo DiCaprio also
there Gigi Hadid who Leo has also been
linked to as for who he left with
one two three four young ladies who
followed the 48 year olds into his
awaiting limo van
all right Leo I see you Leo and there
was no sign of Sydney Sweeney's fiancee
Jonathan DeVito or engagement ring after
romance rumors swirls between her and
co-star Glenn Powell
meanwhile Serena Williams and Carly
Kloss both use the Met Gala steps as
their personal pregnancy announcement
s tonight the right night to announce
this news this is the most important
night in fashion of course and I'm
honestly surprised I could keep it a
secret this long so have you been able
to keep it as a big winter coat big
winter
that's Serena's husband Alexis Ohanian
sweetly following instructions the
tennis Legend broke the news of
five-year-old Olympia was going to be a
big sister by saying she quote was so
excited when Anna winter invited the
three of us
I think my kids are gonna love it my
daughter's gonna gag mom of two cardi B
went big with four metcala looks she
also kept it real with us on her way up
anybody got an Etc and I have a headache
and I cannot drink with a headache
am fans heads were kinda exploding
thinking Anna winter confirmed romance
rumors when she showed up with Bill shy
as hurtless one however we're told they
are not in a relationship they have
simply been great friends for two
decades but what about recent X's Diddy
and young Miami who showed up hand to
the aunt are they back together again
we're just having a good time we don't
put titles on it it's like my best
friend in the world the duo left the
event before the carpet even wrapped why
I didn't really like my seats
oh
bed from Robert Pattinson and tsuki
Waterhouse to Viola Davis and Julius
Tennant the night was filled a cute
couple moments maybe are the kids
jealous of us right now is definitely
jealous now do they approve of your
looks oh they of course they approve
both caveat coffee is a tougher judge
[Music]
thank you you look
absolutely and Paris you don't look too
bad you're sending you so much it's a
wonderful evening
that newlywed glow well Priyanka Chopra
had 15 month old malty as part of her
Glam Squad her love story with Nick
Jonas kinda began at the Mets in 2017.
I'm a circle for you we walked the
carpet my first met and Nick was kind
enough to escort me on behalf I was just
there to manage her train James Corden
and wife Julie Perry seem to be enjoying
life after The Late Late Show met galico
chair and former tennis pro Roger
Federer they have some tips how's
retirement treating you about
retirement's good I'm having a good time
with the kids as for bass Lerman and his
wife Catherine the gala holds a special
place in their hearts one year ago we
were celebrating Elvis on this carpet
with a whole cast how's the Presley
family doing because I know that they
became quite the family worked on Elvis
tickets we've all just come through it
now and there's a bit of a debriefing
there's a moment now everyone's just
taking a breath
foreign